So how do we compute this?
Well, first,
we want to be able to create a discrete
inverse response function from the data.
And we refer to this as,
let's say, say G of Z,
and what we're basically interested
in for each pixel site, and
I just showed you three in
the last image In image j.
I just showed you five, and
I basically showed the plot was,
were about 15 of them.
For each pixel site, and
we can choose a few good number of them,
all of the images,
we will compute the values, and
again we do this I'm in log here,
of both the exposures, And,
a time, to compute a function g(z).
I mean, doing in this log
allows us to do addition.
Otherwise, remember we would be
doing this as a multiplication.
Of course, what we have now is
an overdetermined linear system for
N pixels over P different
exposure images.
So again, we have P different
exposure images and we have N pixels.
We basically started off with I,
side pixel I and image J.
Now of course we have a number of
pixels that we want to measure,
and the number of exposures.
Remember, last time we basically showed
5, we had 15, and I had 3 points.
So N was 3, and
P was 15 to create those plots.
Now, of course, what we can do now is
create a system of linear equations,
log of exposure, log of the time itself.
And then, basically, subtracting by this
and this basically let's us do, you know,
these squared difference.
Of course, what we basically now do
is come up with a fitting term and
a smoothness term.
And this is the,
kind of way we basically solve these
types of linear optimization problems.